la regla de n 1 nos permite predecir
cuántos picos esperamos ver en la señal
de un espectro de rm n si pensamos en la
señal para un protón si ese protón tiene
n protones vecinos esperaríamos ver n
más un picos en el espectro de rm la
regla de n 1 solo aplica cuando los
protones vecinos son químicamente
equivalentes los unos con los otros en
el último vídeo vimos esta molécula y
nos enfocamos en este protón en rojo y
vimos que esta señal justo aquí es
debido al protón en rojo y también
hablamos de este protón aquí en azul
estas señales debido al protón en azul
veamos al protón en rojo veamos cuántos
protones vecinos tenemos si piensas en
este carbono y piensas en el carbono
vecino en este carbono de aquí
este protón es un vecino cierto tenemos
hasta ahora un vecino
ahora vamos a este carbono vecino no hay
protones en este carbono tenemos un
total de solo un protón vecino para el
protón en rojo un protón vecino
es igual a 1 veremos uno más uno picos
uno más uno es igual a dos esperamos ver
dos picos en la señal para el protón en
rojo aquí está la señal y veremos
nuestros dos picos llamamos a esto 2
ley
la señal para el protón en rojo se
desdobla en dos picos debido a la
presencia del protón azul vecino hagamos
lo mismo con el protón azul si pensamos
en la señal para el protón azul cuántos
protones vecinos tenemos si continuamos
con el carbono vecino este carbono de
aquí no tiene protones y en este carbono
por supuesto tenemos un protón así que
solo tenemos un vecino n es igual a 1
veremos en el azul picos uno más uno es
igual a dos veremos dos picos vayamos
acá a la señal para el protón en azul y
veamos nuestros dos picos obtenemos un
'doblete' un vecino nos da un doblete
aquí qué pasa con los protones de aquí
estos protones en magenta cuántos
vecinos tenemos para esos protones
al oxígeno y no tiene protones no hay
vecinos por lo que n es igual a cero
tiene más un picos
y más uno es igual a uno esperaríamos
solo un pico para
esta señal
de estos tres protones equivalentes por
supuesto que esta es la señal con solo
un pico y la llamamos
ley
y hagamos otro también vimos esta
molécula en el último vídeo cierto por
aquí y veamos a nuestros protones
esperamos una señal para el protón en
azul y una señal para estos protones en
rojo aquí pensemos en los protones en
rojo primero cuántos protones vecinos
tenemos vamos a los carbonos vecinos y
tenemos un protón un vecino por lo que n
es igual a 1 'esperamos uno más uno
picos así que esperamos dos picos la
señal para los protones en rojo necesita
tener dos picos esta de aquí
un pico y ahí está el segundo pico por
lo que tenemos un doblete qué pasa con
la señal para el protón en azul si
obtenemos una señal para el protón en
azul
cuántos protones vecinos tenemos vamos
con el carbono de junto y tenemos 12
vecinos para el protón en azul tenemos a
dos vecinos n es igual a 2
esperamos n son picos así que tenemos
dos más uno que es igual a
tres picos para esta señal esta señal de
aquí tenemos 1 2 y 3
tres picos a los cuales llamamos green
bien vayamos al siguiente veamos este de
aquí tenemos un bromo etano dibujemos
primero los protones en este carbono
tenemos dos protones y en este carbono
tenemos
protones
empecemos con la señal para estos
protones de aquí estos son equivalentes
esperaríamos una señal para esos
protones y cuántos vecinos tienen esos
protones vamos al carbono de al lado
tenemos 12 tenemos dos vecinos por lo
que n es igual a 2 esperaríamos n mazón
picos por lo que dos más uno es igual a
tres esperaríamos un triplete para esta
señal y aquí está nuestro triplete uno
dos y tres picos para esa luego solo
pensemos en la señal para estos dos
protones cuántos vecinos tienen esos dos
protones vamos al carbono de juntos
dos y tres vecinos n es igual a tres por
lo que tres más uno es igual a cuatro
esperaríamos una señal con cuatro picos
para los protones en azul aquí está
nuestra señal para cuatro picos 1 2
y cuatro llamamos a este cuarteto cuando
son cuatro picos lo llamamos war
tú
continuamos con otro ejemplo veamos esta
molécula de aquí y primero dibujemos los
protones
en este carbono
es protones aquí están los tres protones
en este otro carbono están otros tres
protones y en este carbono sólo habría
un protón y aquí está pensemos ahora en
cuántas señales esperaríamos ver sin
pensar en la regla de n 1 o en el
acoplamiento espn espn aquí la señal
para estos protones estos protones están
en el mismo ambiente que estos protones
hay una señal para esos y luego
esperaríamos una señal para este protón
aquí en un ambiente distinto pensamos en
la señal para los protones en rojo
primero cuántos protones vecinos tienen
los protones en rojo vamos al carbono de
junto y este es el carbono de junto para
esos dos protones rojos y hay un vecino
n
es igual a 1
uno más uno es igual a dos esperaríamos
un doblete para esta señal y ese debe de
ser este de aquí ésta es una ampliación
de lo que estás buscando y no es
exactamente el mismo dibujo que he hecho
lo dibujé a mano por lo que no es
perfecto pero puedes ver que hay dos
picos aquí este está representando estos
dos picos de ahí
esa es esta señal y qué pasa con el
protón en azul cuántos vecinos tiene el
protón azul vemos este carbono y vemos
el carbono de juntos
este es el carbono de junto 1 2 y 3 este
carbono también es el vecino de este
carbono 1 2 3 un total de 6 n es igual a
6 esperaríamos n más un picos 6 más uno
es igual a 7 esperaríamos 7 picos a lo
cual llamamos septeto déjame continuar
escribiendo
tú aquí y veamos esta señal debería ser
esta de aquí y esto es muy difícil de
dibujar nuevamente esta es una
ampliación de lo que estás buscando
esperaríamos siete picos 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7
esa es la idea de la regla de n 1 y
hablemos un poco más del acoplamiento
espn espn y de cuando esperaron la señal
si tienes protones químicamente
equivalentes no muestran acoplamiento y
espn espn si veo estos dos protones de
aquí estos dos protones están en el
mismo ambiente que estos dos protones
piensa en la simetría esperaríamos solo
una señal en el espectro de rm n y estos
protones no van a desdoblar a estos
protones aunque sean vecinos porque son
químicamente equivalentes unos con otros
los protones químicamente equivalentes
no muestran desdoblamiento espn espn
ahora veamos estos ejemplos de aquí
abajo
y de lo que hemos estado hablando es de
los protones vecinos este protón y este
protón dividirán sus señales y se
encuentran en diferentes ambientes se
observa el desdoblamiento
estamos hablando de estos protones
vecinos de aquí pero si tienes esta
situación
hagamos una vez más a este el protón
rojo ya este el protón azul hay un
carbono extra entre los dos el
desdoblamiento generalmente no se
observa en esta situación por lo que los
protones azul y rojo no se desdoblarán
generalmente
y hay excepciones pero para espectros
simples de rm deberás pensar en esta
situación
en la izquierda aquí
estos protones están demasiado lejos
para sentir algún efecto y finalmente es
posible tener desdoblamiento de protones
en el mismo carbono si están en
diferentes ambientes cierto si este
protón está en un ambiente diferente a
este protón es posible que se observe el
desdoblamiento y hablaremos más de ese
tema en el siguiente vídeo